remove all doubt in anyone's mind that
we will not have a reconciliation we
will have a reconciliation bill that is
for sure it is not
some major cataclysm
uh if there isn't a vote today mark my
words
the the infrastructure bill will be
passed and a version of the
reconciliation bill will be as well we
will not be able to vote for the
reconcil for the infrastructure bill
until the reconciliation bill has passed
so we're in the same place and it's a
shame for that because no two bills
should ever be linked together to the
point where you're going to let it
perfect be the enemy of the good
senator joe manchin there
at this hour we are told that the house
will not have any votes before 9 pm we
don't know the status of whether the
infrastructure bill is coming up whether
there's a deal on the reconciliation
bill we don't do know this
joe manchin laid down a marker today and
the washington post took note saying joe
manchin delivers a dagger to the heart
of the progressive cause they can huff
and puff all they want but they won't
blow down the west virginia democrats
house because he correctly reads public
opinion re-engineering the fabric of
american life is modern progressivism's
whole point its adherents believe that
the nation is in crisis crises demand
immediate and wide-ranging action not
incremental change or tinkering around
the edges their ambitions however can
only prevail in a democracy if they are
supported by public opinion that's where
we are at this hour let's bring in our
panel ben dominic publisher of the
federalist mara liason national
political correspondent of national
public radio and trey gowdy former
congressman from south carolina
mara uh we don't know where this is
going we do know that um it's going to
be less than 3.5 trillion in the
reconciliation bill if it happens yes
it's definitely going to be less i think
we've known that for quite some time but
we just didn't know the actual
parameters of the negotiation and i
think the big
progress that was made today is that joe
manchin said in public before a camera
what he's been saying in private and
actually on paper in this memo that he
and uh chuck schumer signed is that his
number top line number is 1.5 trillion
he has some other substantive
demands he wants new entitlement
programs social safety net programs to
be means tested he wants to roll back
the trump tax cuts including carried
interest uh so he has a whole lot of
things that he cares about now he did
not say that this was a hard and fast
number and he wasn't flexible at all he
said you know we're going to negotiate
so somewhere between 3.5 and 1.5
is where they'll end up if they can get
a deal among themselves and that's a big
gift right listening to progressives
saying listen we're going to vote
against this the infrastructure
bipartisan infrastructure bill if we
don't have a deal a vote on
reconciliation
yeah brett i give credit to the
progressives in the house they watch
very carefully as the freedom caucus on
the republican side prove that you can
get a lot more famous opposing your own
leadership than you can fighting with
the other side and fame has become the
ultimate
political virtue i will say this jinsaki
used the word democracy the washington
post used the word democracy let's lay
aside the fact that they tried to ram it
through well the parliamentarian and put
everything in one bill let's give them
credit for liking democracy
you know brett you and i won the same
number of counties in west virginia that
joe biden did
and arizona was less than one-half of a
percentage point so don't be lecturing
joe manchin and kirsten cinema about
democracy
speaking of jen saki she was asked about
the white house potentially losing
control of this whole deal today
this is how democracy works i know it
feels foreign because there wasn't much
that happened over the last couple of
years but how it works is the american
people elect their elected officials the
president of the united states puts
forward a bold and ambitious proposal
and then everybody negotiates about it
they have different points of view
that's how democracy should work we're
in the midst of it right now we're not
trying to paint over how messy it looks
from the outside we know that
ben
well we're not actually a democracy just
to point that out for a point of
clarification if we were then we would
be fine with majorities running
pell mel toward all of these types of
extreme steps uh even if they were the
slimmest majorities there's an important
reason and and the founders really
believed in it that we are not that way
and our government does not work that
way and that's why joe manchin is so
important in this moment you know look
he he reads politics very well and not
just in his own state but in i think the
broader dynamic and i think in this
moment there ought to be a lot of
critiques of the approach that nancy
pelosi used because at the end of the
day she may have missed an opportunity
to achieve a package that could be much
more perhaps than what mansion would the
mansion's number would be but far less
than what progressos are currently
demanding taking the step that she did
in terms of linking these measures
together in a way that i think was
politically unwise is coming back to
bite her in a big way today you know we
always knew that senator mentioned was
going to be crucial in this whole thing
we've talked to him here on this show
many times and uh asked him specific
questions today mar you're right with
the 1.5 trillion top line that he talked
about take a listen to this and reaction
on the progressive side
i guess for them to get theirs elect
more liberals
but don't i'm not asking them to change
i'm willing to come from zero to one
five my top line has been 1.5 because i
believe in my heart that what we can do
and what the needs we have right now and
what we can afford to do without being
basically changing our whole society to
an entitlement mentality which senator
are we negotiating with is this june
mansion is it september mansion is it
august mansion
will december mansion be a different you
know will that this be a different
senator that pops up
it's actually july 28th manchester yes
the date of the memo that's right and it
hasn't changed since then
but look you know what he said was just
basic facts the reason democrats are in
this fix is because they have a gigantic
agenda and a minuscule majority and they
failed to win the extra seats in the
house and senate that they thought they
were going to win in 2020 that
republicans thought they were going to
win in 2020 and that's just reality and
as joe manchin said today i've never
been a liberal he's representing a state
that trump won by what 29 points
so
you know like that song in hamilton they
don't have the votes and they're going
to have to compromise
and that's just the way it is trey
you've seen this play before and speaker
pelosi has pulled rabbits out of hats
legislatively before
we don't know what's going to happen
tonight do you think she could cobble
this together
it depends it depends on how many
republican senators continue to call
republican members of the house and
asked them to vote for the
infrastructure bill so kevin mccarthy
has a job to do here too which is keep
the republicans coalesced
i love aoc's political strategy which is
insult the person whose vote you need
i just don't think it's going to work
but let's take it on the flip side ben
what about those moderate republicans
who look at the 1.2 trillion
infrastructure bill and say you know
this is a chance to finally build that
bridge to finally fix that road that
i've been talking about fixing to my
constituents forever
maybe i should vote for it i mean is the
politics of the moment more important
than the bridge at home
i think that's a big question but headed
into a midterm year uh you know delivery
of that bridge does you know is going to
become less and less of their priority
and one one more note on this you know
the the kind of of jabs that we've seen
not just at joe manchin but today from
some progressives at arizona senator
cinema
have really been become more and more
aggressive during this point uh you know
the idea said by one member today that
she hasn't shown us anything but a
designer purse that's the not the kind
of insult that's going to come across
very well with someone who's navigating
a situation and who last i checked is
has 40 popularity among republicans in
arizona and either one of them could
become republicans and changes the
dynamic you get senate majority leader
mcconnell all right thank you all hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else